welcome to this video playing Hester
best horses are best as I have learnt is
the meaning flecked island yep thailand
and let's play you though should an
incal sloth this line now I've forgotten
I have forgotten not displayed g6 I
really have forgotten the line let's see
yup White's basic ideas to play be for a
for later and the tech black structure
very often there is a piece sacrifice on
b5 that that helps why'd you two break
through okay so okay I probably need to
challenge this piece
John latex probably want to prepare you
five I can go reform but I wasn't
entirely sure I'd if I thanks this is
ugly hmm
yeah this wasn't really planned I had
ever looked at d5 hang her home so one
this wasn't intended at all no eating
your way of five Wow
yeah that's very ugly chest very ugly
book yeah I don't have any after after
this this f6 misstep it gets very tricky
to play this position
no not sure if I should lose this
quickly and it's still still fairly
fairly resilient but of course it's a
very very ugly chest okay Queenie 72 f
seven maybe a night might go to g3 can
maybe just cover this and play a rookie
seven and rookie age if possible
okay he can do this nigeria and so on
but is it is a decisive my Reggie Sam
Bishop is terrible anyway I think you
should go away for something at it at
one point but ok ok check check some
trades are certainly helpful maybe here
getting rid of the snide on yeah getting
red I guess you needs to retreat it ok
no oops and let's take let's go to the
home yeah the bad thing is that it stays
bad it is even a bad end game but can
the end game is something that I'm less
afraid of
yeah I can maybe take and plain ig5 at
least activating the night yeah come on
let's do that yes but is it is such a
problem it's night to a form what
exactly is going on
here and Queenie eight back it still
looks ugly but I've been in far worse
earlier pretty sure 23
can I go h5 bishop age six or am I
getting getting too ambitious here 94 is
also possible 94 check on d6 Bishop f8y
not actually
queen III know Queenie two checks on d6
takes on d6 hmm Bishop f8 you might have
night e 6 then that could be a problem
96
mmm takes takes bishop f 896 time
morning I take it as Queen g for me to
know or the bad idea probably 94
check
yeah this cost me some time this is this
94 maybe it was okay but I couldn't
really evaluate it properly
can try to activate with bishop age six
at the end check check check I get some
maturity here that's why I can take that
wow what an end game is got a ton of
pawns oh now I get in we shouldn't be
five check
check check check check check check I'm
but a game it's right what fits on time
another it's not much falling my way at
the moment I mean it really let me out
of this out of this terrible position
and then I still lose it yeah this is
this this this was bad young just up
sorry 94 was a bad idea I guess maybe I
can yeah at least in connection with
that it was it was totally unnecessary
here you can do whatever I don't know
the worst is over the night on g5 I can
just just play this position even this
is probably okay yeah then you had this
this mess going on yeah I know they got
some cool to play him and of course you
must play must pay quickly in this in
this time check check check
yeah I needed to do that then he
blundered the night and your black
should win but I don't have any time I
should try I should maybe I should be
able to promote the poem really no
Bishop b4 Bishop f5 it's just a piece
check basically but ok we didn't I
didn't have any time check and this
sorry it's to Bishop so it was just one
Bishop AB should be five wins quite
easily actually it's a total palm locate
but okay I have eight seconds and it was
not a really great position to her to
pre move yeah yeah not not much working
at the moment but the main problem was
the bloody opening Wow f6 was at least
97 maybe can I can play Bishop d7 but
the whole thing after this is just plain
ugly and with the comp wants to play if
I and says black it's good okay maybe I
should have thought here a bit a bit
more it looks yeah yeah there is some
Pointer of the slim look at this it's
okay interesting and here also okay okay
so i can do that I just must play a five
set of e six yeah that this wasn't great
what was pretty clear but um okay i
didn't i didn't really see you five hmm
ok ok thanks for watching